you tried to kip out of the thing
no the carrier or maybe we made it
out of it on a ledge and i went
i'm just trying to get out of a plastic
bag
like you can carry it around in that
chest
listen it can hold it it's totally fine
what's going on
the youtube stream has not started so
where is this is this streaming anywhere
probably
we're on plays
oh well you know what look folks can we
just restart it all yeah we can do that
let's restart it all let's let's do it
again
well i wonder why
[Music]
[Music]
push
up
one
two three
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by kershaw.com
you'll look better but more importantly
you'll feel better
unless you have covert then you'll
probably die
proud.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm oh that's good suckatuch that's
delicious that is uh that is uh sip
number two hey if it just so you know
the technical difficulties really
quickly for people on youtube no
conspiracy no quarter black uh garrett
is sick home he does not have the kovitz
we have people here of course helping
fling in we wish you the best uh quarter
black with your quarter simple cell when
you come back in
that's so terrible and expect him in st
jude's uh advertisement before uh your
local movie
showing soon he has an adorable blanket
yes
uh no so so no conspiracy there we just
have had some technical issues but uh
net we have a lot to get to today donald
trump jr is on the show boom really
excited about that he's going to be
commentating some fights this weekend
between evander hollyfield and vittor
belfort so uh place your bets on the
roided up athlete of your choice and
that's not just in case you want to come
at me for defamation or slander i don't
know which one is the written versus uh
uttered um
vittor belford tested positive in the
ufc really several times and evander
holyfield was part of that steroid ring
but you know they both have decent guys
right just you know
all natural um and one and we are going
to be talking about quite a bit here
today yeah
one thing that i really wanted to touch
on and i don't know if this is you know
trending like chris pratt who didn't do
anything wrong but everyone just looking
for a scalp on a slow news day is cnn
has been talking about this all day the
icu bed shortage the nursing staff
shortage
why everything that you and i shouldn't
speak in absolutes but why absolutely
everything you have been told is a lie
is wrong a lot of people out there think
covet has happened hospitals have been
overrun and that's why there are no beds
in the icus that's not true
and i will explain to you point by point
why that is the case we'll also be
watching the the new matrix trailer yes
um
because my team hates me
we have to do something like that so uh
before we get dave actually dave landau
how are you i'm good you're so ahoy oh
boy uh you have an announcement to make
i do but first actually just found out
before the show gerald a oh has an
announcement to make of his own is that
okay dave we good yeah go for it cool so
yeah my uh my wife and i are expecting
kiddo number two hey
really congratulations i knew this yes
we're gonna have another uh another kid
coming up how far along are you very
early on in the process okay i think
it's like uh right around that eight to
ten week range okay you should know
these things more precisely yeah well
you know that's early you knew a couple
weeks ago right around your last
vacation
exactly if you could time it back i
think branson yeah
yes that's because branson is the right
he's a storybook romance who hasn't made
a baby in bran we went on down to the
dolly parton rodeo a subsidiary of
medieval times after uh you know
i get a little wet after watching yakov
smearing off
uh acrobats extraordinaire and then
going on the non-gambling riverboat
listen there are tons of crowds gamble
just
yes you can get the chips and then i saw
the ripley's believe it or not which
gets the crappy leftover like oh is that
uh is that the uh stunt man's judge
dread costume yeah i didn't believe it
congratulations hey guys you can leave a
comment that's the best thing well we
haven't obviously usually comment on on
issues where we ask you guys questions
but come on let gerald know that you
love him give him a congratulations nice
comments yeah please and uh well dave
and dave also dave also has a major yeah
what's here
oh uh uh well we should definitely
reverse this uh i'm gonna be on a
fishing show
hey
okay that's cool too yeah oh oh he's a
fan and he's watching um no seriousness
uh check out
basquehunter.tv it's on the pursuit
channel which you can check local
listings sorry next week i'm on the
season finale uh it's my buddy mike
mckinstry it's a really really fun show
and then it'll be up on youtube after
that and you can watch me looking for
bass did you catch anything unlike uh no
are you supposed to reveal that or is
that like the big thing he was looking
for bass you were looking for nookie so
i was gonna do that and then i held off
because i got a little eyeball from
stephen
but
but yeah i did i caught i did catch fish
yeah i'm not gonna save many fish yeah
well you know you know gerald caught a
little more hey promo code is uh crowder
comeback you get twenty dollars off a
one-year subscription right now you
wanna join it mug club just dave is also
uh in uh spokane uh the spokane company
club in washington this friday and
saturday at 7 30 and 10 30. okay before
we move on to
larry elder being hit with eggs by a
racist in a gorilla mask i don't think
she was a racist i don't think she could
afford a new mask
it's still wrong i mean could you
imagine someone threw eggs at barack
obama in a gorilla mask like oh
president
you know yeah it would just be awful and
rightfully so like
like seriously it's just everything
about this is ridiculous also i've
learned that uh uh uh private security
in some cases are useless
but before we get to that
lefty tick tockers and the nursing
scandal right now uh
left to stick doctors they want you to
know that you can refer to your daughter
this is where we are okay
it's offensive uh to refer to your
daughter
as
princess
so i don't know if this is considered an
unpopular opinion but if you have a
daughter you need to stop calling her
princess if you do the way that disney
has branded the princess is based on her
beauty as her most important asset this
term also encourages the damsel in
distress that needs to be rescued by a
man
focus on their intelligence or integrity
or any other character trait why don't
we call girls scientist engineer doctor
like my wife plays a good doctor yes
it involves a hammock no
my daughter's father called her princess
yesterday and i had to lecture him again
because we do not use that term in this
house my daughter's father my own sister
i hope you threw your tuna casserole
against the wall i'll call her that
maybe i come across as very controlling
yeah i wonder why he left it's a very
harmful word and she shouldn't look up
to that
i hate you yeah
no because we wouldn't want uh we
wouldn't want anyone to perpetuate of
course the stereotype of princess
that's not something that we would uh we
would ever want there uh yeah
a little more timely there uh
as long as you're a man yeah as long as
you're a man it's like oh no listen
listen this is just uh i believe i'm a
woman really how many transgender
individuals uh are saying i want to be a
woman why so i can become a scientist no
they want to become a woman so they can
have big old fake tits and clown makeup
let's be really clear about it
okay and all of a sudden it's like oh
caitlyn bruce jenner is now caitlyn
jenner is dressed like a barbie wearing
a corset with those dimensions and is
wearing a princess tiara but hey well no
that's fine just not for biological
women well do you see the example she's
she's like oh princess what do you need
and she's like why can't we call him
scientist cause i don't call my son oh
scientist what do you need oh well i
don't think i don't believe he's ever
been to an accredited university yeah i
don't believe that she has a degree for
me to call her also one
like it's a bit early to become and i
love how she pay into her husband yeah
her husband as my child's father right
what is it with labels in you like is
that not appropriate are you not husband
and wife anymore that's fine you could
say oh my god i wouldn't be i don't know
well well i hope if you leave i feel
that you uh don't try and take any uh
said finances from your child's father
since you're such a strong independent
yeah that's true no no no no no i want
my cake and eat it too
i just think everything's terrible don't
call them princess look do you know why
do you know why particularly men will
call their daughter princess that's
what's most common yeah there's a great
book called wild at heart actually that
you should read it talks about how every
young man needs a battle to fight a
dragon to slay and a princess to save
that's also why women have been told for
a very long time until recently that you
don't just want to give it all away that
you want the man to pursue you fathers
call their daughters princesses because
they want to elevate them and they hope
that women think highly of themselves
they're young girls and they develop
self-esteem so that other men end up
esteeming them and treating them as a
princess that's the idea the idea is
they're saying you're so special i'm
going to treat you like a princess to
act as though that comes from anything
other than love by the way by the way
there have been princesses there have
been queens who've been very
accomplished yes
i don't know why you're knocking them
she just doesn't like me like you just
say that many liked horses they liked
horses and long hair they had good
quotes let them eat cake
that's all i got some are better than
others it just doesn't matter you're
just pretending to be offended by
something right and then you're going on
tick tock trying to lecture that you're
a white woman stop acting like you're
not the second worst
your daughter if you continue down this
line is going to be the absolute worst
child in the order of worst it goes
south african prince there you go
princess uh
yeah your daughter's gonna treat men
like garbage yeah because of you and be
single until and then never be happy and
then overvalue her
her sexual value in the marketplace when
she's in her 20s because she's going to
think that uh well i believe i identify
as a chemical engineer but you're not no
maybe biochemist but you're none of
those things you got a gender studies
degree and you dropped out of that and
then demanded someone else pay your
student loans are you calling me
princess that would be a step up i think
you should shut up and hopefully find a
nice home and a gutter now uh new world
order is something that does bother me
this is trending number three right now
what because someone said the quiet part
out loud oh
doctor
well australian doctor i don't know i
don't know does that count i don't know
what kind of vetting they do there come
on it's a penal colony
[Music]
what do you get what are you getting a
major and rape and a minor in in in keel
hauling
so that's what i call my daughter major
rape yes mr rape
uh hey women can be majors too yeah yeah
what you got a problem with you
i'm sorry the rank is what threw me on
so australian public health chief dr
carrie chant
just said this this is why it's trending
these words actually at the moment um we
will be looking at what contact tracing
looks like in the new world order and
yes it will be pubs and clubs and other
things if we have a positive case there
our response may be differently
different if we know that people are
fully vaccinated first off good on her
good on all of australia for getting the
first signer we've seen without man
hands there you go that is nice that is
nice that is a i don't want to say
normal yeah
at at least uh uh an average it's signer
it just doesn't need to be like a
seinfeld episode doesn't yeah a
non-three-ring circus right
signer i still think it's fake yeah uh i
just think they said this out well
usually i don't like to get into
conspiracy theories because people the
term new world order right has often
been attributed to people who are
creating conspiracies or wrestling but
she said this out loud and uh didn't
someone else wasn't there someone who
taught i feel like this is something
that has actually been talked about
you know what this is this is ivermectin
for humans you want a nobel prize as an
antiviral and this is inhalable or these
are the tablets steroids
so let me show you
i was going to do this anyways earlier
see this
see this faucet you see this bill gates
i'm going to kill those priority
murderers you're hitting with a bio
weapon you monster you want to suppress
me you want to kill me you son of a you
damn demon you think i'm easy to kill
you damn monster
that's a hell of a plug for topo find
if it weren't for the movements that
actually can't be caught by a 60 frame
rate right um
everything you just said is entirely
right
and he's talking about he went on to
talk about the new world order that he
said in the new world order and she's
like ah i misspoke what i meant is one
world government
so
look this is something they're taught
and we're going to get to uh some more
what they've talked about on cnn today
they want to force you let's let's not
be confused here that the left believes
uh in your right to choose when it comes
to anything outside of
murdering a baby inside the room they
don't believe in your right to choose
when it comes to what car you can drive
what kind of food you can eat what kind
of place you can live and what kind of
transportation you can use drinks um
drinks big gulps
nor
what you can do as it relates to
experimental experimental to new
vaccines look this is the only thing
anyone if anyone talks about the
vaccines this is the issue here i think
that if you
you weigh the risks and rewards just
like anything else yeah and you think
that it's worth uh the reward you should
take the vaccine yeah and there are some
people who cannot there are people with
actual medical conditions like gbs this
is something i run into with my wife
it's a nerve condition that she woke up
from at was triggered by anesthesia she
can't even take a flu shot these things
exist and anyone who says that we have
long-term studies
you're lying it can't you can't now it
doesn't mean that there's anything wrong
with the vaccine no one is saying that
but the problem is when you go out and
you so overreach that it's a lie that
people can recognize well guess what
that's when you create people who don't
trust you right and we'll get to some of
those demographics here in the country
in a second uh but first this is
something that was um
i would say surprising to me that it was
surprising to our government
but it's not yeah
the taliban announced the new government
leadership and then
lincoln i swear to you all right that
blinken was absolutely shocked
at their lack of diversity that's not a
joke here's a clip yesterday the taliban
named a new interim government
we're assessing the announcement but
despite professing that a new government
would be inclusive
the announced list of names consists
exclusively of individuals who are
members of the taliban or their close
associates
and no women
we understand that taliban has presented
this as a caretaker cabinet
we will judge it and them
by its actions
the international community has made
clear its expectation that the afghan
people deserve an inclusive government
yeah well look
one in one hand and [ __ ] in the other
blink and see which one fills up first
we're really hoping the taliban includes
someone this is the difference in the
united states someone loses their office
if they don't
fervently support a george floyd mural
in the taliban they're still enforcing
sharia law and they're going to stone
women to death if they're even accused
of adultery and like he's hopefully we
see some good representation
do you have any idea how much they're
laughing at you oh my god she can't well
the women can't drive to work that's why
they're like well it's a transportation
issue yes i love how he's focused on the
lack of diversity
not on the fact that there's a country
run by terrorists with our tanks and
blackhawks what the hell is the matter
with you yeah they're terrorists you're
not diverse
they have our blackhawks for crying out
like do you have any idea what they're
gonna do with the women i can show you
the world
shining shimmering bye bye
they're going to toss them from black
hawks this is the actual leader the
supreme leader sorry of the taliban
according to uh
according to former vice president joe
biden why give them the respect of
pronouncing it as they would i think
it's funny it's like a joke to me yeah
to us but it's not him they're dead
serious yes they're like we don't want
to mispronounce we don't want to
mispronounce we could offend the guys
who took all of our weapons and murdered
people right yeah we wouldn't want to
offend the people who mutilate their
women and uh uh allow them no rights
what's up so the talib taliban
supreme leader jaya batula
you know what i can't pronounce it the
taliban
the [ __ ] leader of the taliban
said in the future all matters of
governance and life in afghanistan will
be regulated by the laws of the holy
sharia okay by the way remember when uh
the left said that sharia law is not a
thing because dr ben carson said i
actually believe that anyone who agrees
with sharia law that it's incompatible
with the constitution and uh you know
why because islam actually particularly
the quran is a political prescription
just as much as it is a religion it
outlines a system of laws and that is
the reason that entire area of the world
has never gotten it right yeah when it
comes to women's rights they can't i
know someone will send me a picture of
someone in iran in the 70s wearing a one
piece right okay they had like three
good years
it was downhill from there check in now
yeah there was a point when that
happened yeah for like three good yeah
three good years write a song about that
one
but even making that point to you it's
like yeah you're just proving exactly
what my point is right they jumped right
back onto it and ruined their lives well
not only they not have women in
government they also banned uh the
taliban women from playing um sports
with the exception of course of the
all-female uh taliban softball champions
so they're pretty yeah they're good oh
yeah those are uh
the one on the right almost looks like
maddie
they live in a nice not in a bad way
they live in a nice three story oh i'm
sorry they were thrown from a nice three
story oh that's right yes that's
they should have known when they were
asked to volunteer to play softball i
mean look can you guys let me
can you guys let me know just comment
is this wha i was watching this going
are we beyond parody
yes did anyone out there here's my
question did anyone out there actually
expect the taliban to be inclusive
not even getting to uh
menstruating persons did they
did we expect them to be inclusive to
women who would you know well and i know
you're thinking synonym no it's not no
apparently did anyone actually out there
expect them to be
fair and to give equal treatment now
i know most of you are going rhetorical
questions to even and don't get so
smarmy in the comment section so my
follow-up question is
did you actually expect the left to
expect equal treatment of women do you
think they actually expected that this
is what surprises me like were they
actually blindsided
oh yeah hey mr taliban hey what
sorry
no that's the uh that's the uh trudeau
song oh my bad oh
yeah i heard the people also getting the
knocks on the door in the dead of night
and getting shot in their beds were also
a little pissed off that there wasn't
more diversity in the assassination
squad you know the talibanist show on
the peacock has a lot of diversity oh
and i think it's important we have to
give credit where it's due it's true
why would you ever even bring it up
that's the problem with america we're so
woke we've become just a clown circus do
you understand what is required
to kill but to win a war this is the
thing i don't think americans have the
stomach for it we may not have the time
to do the whole woke military segment
today but i don't think that amer do you
know what a war do you know how you win
a war you go in
you destroy all enemies you level
everything you enslave the women which
is i'm not saying it's right this is
what happened though since the beginning
of time up until the evil empire that is
the united states you take all of their
resources
and you make sure that it is so brutal
so swift that no one else even dare
speak
up about challenging you
oh and instead we go in and we get we
don't take the resources we don't take
their oil we try to build up a democracy
and we ask for nothing more than the
land in which to bury the dead who died
for them that's i our military's capable
of winning wars i our people
at the desks the people like blinkens
don't have the stomach for it and i
don't think that americans have the
stomach for winning a war today no we
used to have people commit suicide
because they could not go to war because
they were not found capable they didn't
have the eyesight or they had a body
condition we've gone from people now
just they don't care they don't care
what it costs to be free the older
brother in the wonder years had flat
feet couldn't join the army he was
depressed for like a week yeah he was i
got flat feet but then he bounced back
with those golden graham commercials he
did
so
and using the f word a lot if you see
the movie uh monster squad yes yeah yeah
watching wayne just throw up
gay slurs it's really something well at
least matt damon stopped so here's
another amen larry elder a woman yes a
uh menstruating person a person so
larry elder who's running for governor
against gavin newsom uh he's been on the
show quite a few times i'm still i won't
have him back until he grows back the
mustache he
was touring a homeless encampment in
venice first
mistake but an insane so he was walking
through venice yes just any part
it was in the greater los angeles area
there you go exactly uh and i warn you
that this will be upsetting a le i don't
know what you call this person a person
in a gorilla mask attacked larry elder a
black candidate for governor by whipping
eggs at him and then assaulted uh his
security guards who were non-violently
protecting him all on camera and as of
this show right now is the airing of
this broadcast it is 10 39
a.m eastern
i don't think that anyone has been
arrested there haven't been any charges
press i don't it's on camera multiple
angles here you go
here's the gorilla mask
all right throwing missed those throws
like throws like a girl
quintessential feminism commits assault
and then is offended when a man says
stop committing assault
all right we won't call your daughter
princess i got it all right
come on guy
you go through the security should be
going through there and just laying
people out
a white woman yelling at a man
black man you're not black enough right
dress in a gorilla mask
with the defense of hitting what is it
it wouldn't have been more offensive had
she gone larry elder
i've taken a lot of lsd and i don't know
what's real anymore i really don't
every day i wake up i'm like that
happened right was that a nightmare
it's a it's a lady i on a a white lady
in a gorilla man and then they will say
committed from those in the right this
person did it to the leading republican
candidate in california in plain view
with several people backing this broad i
assume in the gorilla mask up and then
assaulting security officers again it's
not that they did this it's that the
left fears no accountability no
retribution whatsoever and that is not a
good path to go down because guess what
someone's going to start dishing out
retribution soon government you need to
do your job media you need to do your
job or the americans who are tired of
getting physically assaulted will do it
for you and i pray that it doesn't come
to that but it will yeah absolutely i'm
kind of offended that she missed from
eight feet well she's a menstruating
person yeah these aren't great athletes
exactly
larry elder should have turned around
like time of the month
you should have just belted her i'm like
i'm sorry i thought you were a gorilla
yeah that's exactly what i was going to
say would you have a defense like if you
got hit first off you've been punched
are you allowed to punch back is it
legal in california i don't know well
he's really stupid but nonetheless could
you be like oh i thought i didn't know
you were a woman how am i supposed to
know you're behind that mask you be
anything i'm sorry princess well next
time i'll get it right ah why put a
tierra on that gorilla mask i would have
just acted like it was real and been
like is that a gorilla riding a bike
wow that's insane just not even
just stop well larry elder godspeed yes
dressing up though as a nazi and calling
someone a nazi they think they can do
whatever they want yeah and then they
just throw it at you that everything you
can't call a girl princess but you can
dress up like a gorilla and attack a
black man i'll give you one even more
obviously the swastika symbol which
really shouldn't be as offensive as it
is because it was originally an indian i
like to take my shirt an indian symbol
for games no it was an indian symbol for
peace the swastika then it was co-opted
however the hammer and sickle which
resulted in far more deaths now let me
be really clear nazis bad deaths from
nazis bad complete condemnation what i'm
saying is that was a co-opted symbol it
wasn't originally a nazi symbol however
the hammer and sickle is responsible for
just as many deaths and you can go to
breweries and pro-labor protests and
find the hammer and sickle
everywhere there is a brewery in
traverse city michigan yes when we were
driving through and i took my
grandmother in law there she was 92 and
she looked up and she saw portraits of
stalin and mao and she almost had almost
had a tear brought to her right because
she was around for it by the way russian
and said uh i i've got to get out of
here i've got to get out here why don't
we treat them the same yeah tens of
millions of people died under that
symbol actually hundreds it's more like
hundreds i was trying a hundred dollars
let's let's let's lowball it and call it
uh somewhere between 50 and 100. yep
well it's also look at the skull and
crossbones on my lower back yeah well
that's just to let people it's a pirate
and also my booty holes poison there
might be some plundering foot there is
going to be pillaging oh my gosh uh this
is something else before we move on here
again i want to get into the nursing
shortage issue and the swastika and
some stories here that i encountered and
also uh gerald did yeah uh but uh before
that look we have this week in biden
before i go to this i have never seen a
president i think this is something that
is that cannot be up for debate i have
never seen a president
in my lifetime and i've watched every
single major presidential debate by the
way going back to
i want to say
mondale uh i used to watch them on
c-span and really watch them online yes
because i wanted to see what they were
about i've never seen any president
abdicate his responsibilities as much
every single time joe biden goes up and
speaks and i'll be going up and speaking
yesterday and that's why i wanted uh
speaking up yesterday he'll be going up
and speaking tomorrow he spoke yesterday
he'll speak tomorrow which is very busy
for him yeah uh i mean 10 minutes two
days so i
want you to watch for this when he comes
up later today
he always says they told me i was told
afghanistan not his fault it was other
advisors kovid not his fault they told
me this i'm not allowed to do this i
have to do this my advisors have said
you have to do x and so this is just a
small portion we could do a clip of this
for 10 minutes you can say what you want
about donald trump say what you want
about george w bush they did not say
well i'm basically a puppet so let me
let me make this as clear as i can this
weekend bite wait if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're from me or
trump and you ain't black you guys are
bad i'm not supposed to be answering all
these questions i'm supposed to leave
but i can't resist your questions i'm
supposed to stop and walk out of the
room here
i'm going to stop but with your
permission i'm going to walk into the
room because i want to say hello
i'm not i'm not supposed to take any
questions but go ahead
i'm not going to answer again now they
gave me a list here
the first person i was instructed to
call on was
kelly o'donnell of nbc
i'll take your questions and as usual
folks they gave me a list
of the people i'm going to call on so
jonathan associated press i'm not going
to punish anybody but everyone should
pay a fair share
i can lay out for i won't now because
they'll shoot me but here's the deal
thank you
and i'm happy to take questions if
that's what i'm supposed to do nancy
whatever you want me to do
i'm sorry i'm gonna just the last
question i'll take and i that i'm really
gonna be in trouble i'm sorry i'm gonna
get in trouble with staff i don't do
this the right way jennifer jacob
bloomberg
[Music]
i'm gonna get in trouble with my pr my
staff yeah go ahead but i pretended
repeatedly that america is back
at the same time you kept in place some
trump-era steel and aluminum sanctions
and i wanted to ask you when you're
having these conversations with european
allies who are very concerned about
these sanctions how do you justify that
and what are your plans 120 days give me
a break
need time
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black
the buck stops
so um he's totally in control uh we have
donald trump jr coming on in 15 minutes
so we're going to move some stuff to a
mug club by the way you can join mug
club crowder come back get twenty
dollars off
uh crowdershop.com if you don't wanna
buy money yeah and the best way to watch
oh that's yeah that's that's the quarter
black gear it's not here uh
the best way to just tune in because
notifications don't necessarily work
because it's a live show monday through
thursday yep 10 a.m eastern we're back
on a regular schedule and of course you
get an hour in addition to on mug club
um so my question to you before i move
on with this is um
why do you think the media before we get
to this why do you believe the media is
pushing the scare tactic no available
beds again we were just before cnn went
to reverse mortgage commercials they
were just talking about in kentucky
extreme measures they've been talking
about how we have icu bed shortages so
um let me uh hold on a second i want to
make sure i get the right montage
because we had to cut some some stuff
short here with uh donald trump jr
coming on
um
oh no that's wrong i have oh we have to
run that clip of the michael
schmerkonisch from cnn you want to do
that now no no we'll do it we'll do it
for mug club club okay we'll do it for
you're going to love
you're going to lose your mind but mug
club but uh uh uh dave can you what are
you doing let's just stop with the uh oh
jeez let's start are
yeah i'm hungry okay well look look
because you guys can't see he's shaking
his leg and we have some built-in forbid
me from eating in the studio stephen no
i didn't forbid you from me yeah she did
i forbid you from talking reese's who
are not a sponsor to this show
we have some built bars in the out there
in the green room just go go go go go go
go go find go go go fine take off your
take off your headphones i have to do
that all right let him go
and um
[Music]
hey dave you trying out those built bars
yeah i am
oh they are symphony of flavors
so what flavor is that
looks like it's a birthday cake why
don't you come over and
have a taste
[Music]
all right really quick before we move on
to the
nursing shortage icu bed shortage lie it
is a sp built bar let me really clear
here bill no one needs to eat protein
bars yeah and people that i don't really
use a lot of supplements these things
taste like candy bars they're really
good that's the only the only reason i
eat them is at night like oh i want
something sweet yeah i eat a billboard
the salted caramel is amazing uh and
they're double chocolate because they
actually put real chocolate in the
billboard like coat it in dark chocolate
so yeah i eat candy in a hat actually i
don't know if you knew that yeah i have
a hat for eating candy so uh yeah it's
really it's really good uh but they are
really good actually the the the uh mint
chocolate one oh yeah that's the that
one
that's token owen's favorite and uh uh
thomas finnegan loves the coconut uh so
go to built.com kryder15 you get 15 off
i will say this i was 260 a big part of
it was fluid yeah after the the surgery
um two weeks i went from 2 33 the
morning of the surgery to 260 in two
weeks so i cut out all sweets yeah then
i cut out all carbohydrates i mean
weight still kept going up so i was
panicking once they removed the fluid i
was down to like 238 and then all i did
was look if i wanted to eat something
that i want i just would eat a build bar
and i dropped back down to 2 30 in
another two weeks so yeah help me from
eating those reese's cups get 30 pounds
of stuff in your lungs and you're like i
should cut out cake
i have no idea maybe maybe michaela
peterson i should only eat ribeye
uh
i actually did accidentally go on the
carnivore diet well the only reason was
because i was by myself recovering by
myself and so i would have to grow like
my own steak and it was just too much
work to make vegetables like i don't
like this anyway you're like i'm just
eating two steaks a night i'm like what
i was like yeah
that's yours it wasn't on purpose
okay i don't want no broccoli i'm with
you i don't want it's a lot of work for
no flavor yeah steaming it i don't know
okay so let's go through the media has
been of course talking about the
hospital bed shortage this is the main
talking point du jour guys we may we may
be five minutes late with donald trump
uh junior let him know um remember this
all started so we need some context here
this information exists in a vacuum we
prepared for a crazy covert surge this
all started
as two weeks
to flatten the curve
let's go let's go the u.s navy hospital
ship mercy is pulling into the port
behind me here in san pedro california
it has 1 thousand much-needed hospital
beds 900 medical personnel and that is
really going to help relieve the
pressure on l.a area hospitals during
this pandemic couldn't make their bed
in massachusetts the state rushed to
increase its hospital bed capacity 22
news state house reporter jody reed
joins us live from boston and jody there
are big questions tonight about whether
the measures the state took early on
were actually necessary
right now two out of the four field
hospitals in the state remain empty in
fact they never even saw a single
patient uk 6.7 million dollar field
hospital at nutter field house is
officially closed
that word today from uk officials based
on the data we have now based on the
models that have been established that
we have now
we don't believe we'll need that field
hospital well that's because i think i
think in that case look that's an
exception i don't think people trusted
the medical personnel at a place called
ruby by the way
where are you going to nutter no no i'm
going to get my transplant at sac tap
yep
i hear that place is nuts right every
time i walk in they keep doing this and
then they hit me yeah that's so strange
they're so childish keep looking at it
every time um and so ball sweat you yes
this is so this was the whole thing
right flat in the curve they had all of
these empty hospitals and buildings i
want to make sure you understand because
now
people are saying well we don't have
enough beds we don't have it well that's
partially true partially true but the
reason why
it's not just because of covid it's not
just because there was a crazy surge of
covenant we weren't ready for it no
that's actually the opposite of what
happened in a lot of these cases so now
the claim is hospitals after you just
saw those empty hospitals for a very
very long time hospitals have no free
beds now when they're over capacity here
you go south carolina hospitals are once
again reaching their limits due to an
influx of cobit 19 patients at the
assade three rivers medical center in
grants pass things are as busy as ever
one hundred percent of the patients in
the icu suffer from the marshal
the current coveted surge is still
overwhelming the hospital we
it's close as you mentioned in the
beginning of the segment of having in
certain areas of the country getting so
close to having full occupancy
that you're going to be in a situation
where you're going to have to make some
very tough choices okay so here's
something uh that a lot of hospitals
operate close to capacity as a business
model period yeah okay uh dr mark boone
the ceo of houston methodist hospital he
actually explained this in august now
i'm just using this as a specific
example right however this is well known
as a business model for the same reason
that we only bought enough studio space
that we were going to use right yeah you
don't want a ton of excess skills you
don't want a ton of excess capacity
that's not only when you're talking
about rent when you're talking if you're
even buying this property talk about
heating cooling utility costs this is
how not to mention staffing this is very
very commonplace so the context matters
let's have uh dr mark boom talk about
this from houston methodist so i pulled
up june 25th 2019 exactly one year ago
and said okay what was our icu capacity
at one year ago today
it was at 95
we are highly experienced at utilizing
our icu beds for the sickest of the sick
patients day in day out as i've said and
it is completely normal
on the bottom right i have i think that
we believe he's actually in front of the
[ __ ] palace let us operate hospitals
how all hospitals operate um
what's different now of course is that
about one in four of those icu patients
are covered patients at our hospital
system right and the top left so clearly
that
non-covalent care has already been
titrated down a little to allow that
level to happen but this is an activity
we do day in day out as i've said
um so we have many levers at our uh in
our ability to adjust our icu usage and
i wanna because your your wife is a
nurse she is and we're going to get to
your story in a second because it's it's
very important and she gave you
permission to talk about it she did yeah
and i had a research running in a
hospital a pregnant nurse pregnant nurse
which is like most of my google history
so
now we're also being told that the the
nurses are burnt out right that the
they're burnt out over them despite the
empty hospitals that you just saw that
were built for this uh and that this is
the reason there is a staffing shortage
again all of this is being crafted so
that you believe a narrative
crack in the front line in the battle
against coven nurses are burned out and
considering leaving the profession all
together the state and nation facing a
nurse shortage that's only expected to
get worse our health care workers are
overworked they're mentally and
emotionally exhausted and now some
valley nurses are leaving the profession
to pursue other careers doctors across
the united states are struggling under
the burden of a fourth wave of
hospitalizations and deaths driven by
the delta variant and the close to 40
percent of americans who remain
unvaccinated
real quick because we have to move this
pretty quickly so look um here's the
reason that there are actually a lot of
nursing shortages it's not because all
of them are burnt out despite what
nurses tell you on tick tock many
hospitals were forced to pause
all elective procedures meaning it was
all hands on deck covered build up new
hospitals for covet exclusively and stop
any treatment for anything other than
cova even though you just heard you know
from houston methodist for example at
any point in time one in four patients
may be coveted what would constitute
elective procedures by the way well
minor things like uh uh heart stints
right heart valve surgery
mammograms kidney stone removal hip and
knee replacements these were all put on
pause back surgery they were all put on
paws and so um what happened was a
record number of nurses were laid off
yeah they were laid off or they were
furloughed which is i guess basically
they don't technically fire a nurse
because that's like we don't really want
to kind of fire you we're going to call
you back in like three months well see
the issue with that is when i saw
furlough with nurses about a year back i
was thinking like when they furlough
prisoners which i remember the first
time i heard about that for those who
don't know it's someone who's in prison
and they let them out for the weekend
that happens that's still a thing yeah
god he had someone whacked yeah he was
like
yeah he left prison to kill someone he
left to kill someone then walked back
into his walk back into his 20 by 40
cell with a wine cellar
so he liked wine the point is not
interchangeable terms nurses who've been
furloughed nurses who've had their hours
cut
in april 2020 says overlay p yeah
a record number 1.4
million healthcare workers 1.4 million
healthcare workers were laid off or had
their hours cut
that's insane
um and of course many of the field
hospitals constructed they never had any
patients no and a lot of the ships
didn't have patience
77 total at uh uh the mercy
more ghost ships right yes
uh 182 total patients for the comfort
new york uh in new york 155 million
spent on tents at stony brook university
zero patients oh my gosh so oh just to
be clear this is a self-inflicted wound
they said we need to flatten the curve
okay we need to flatten the curve and
all elective procedures and so then a
record number of health care workers
were laid off and so what happens is you
don't have the staffing for a lot of
these beds that are already operating at
capacity anyway
this is a self-inflicted wound because
of mass media hysteria let's be really
really clear also i would make the
argument that someone who needs serious
cardiovascular surgery should probably
be given priority over someone with a
milder case of covet that's just opinion
i'm not a doctor and neither are you
well i think they should certainly be
given it over zero patients right
it's like i'm sorry there's no one here
i can't help
you so now the claim is that well nurses
are quitting because of now these
burdens that come with treating covet
patients so they want you to believe
that now even though the record number
of layoffs now a lot of nurses are
leaving and that is true yeah but it's
because of they they're just they just
can't even this is what they're saying
now
clippy uh clip l1
pen ldi study that looked at hospital
understaffing in new york and illinois
found that quote each additional patient
per nurse was associated with
significant increases in the odds of
nurses reporting poor outcomes including
job dissatisfaction intent to leave
their job and high burnout the latest
surge is pushing his health care workers
to the breaking point we've had people
literally walk off the job
because they couldn't take it anymore
somebody walking off of their shift at
this hospital we've had people who
have people walk off their shift they
walk in the right chest
because they just couldn't take it
anymore in the state of mississippi some
2 000 nurses have quit since the
pandemic it's it's every day i mean just
people can't take it's not because they
don't want to do a good job
we've made it really hard for them with
this influx to our health care system
okay let's stress let's cut this because
it's just going to keep going on stress
burnout fatigue actually no there's
another reason that there's a staffing
shortage with nurses that nurses are
walking off the job hmm
there you go i was actually going to ask
you before before pause it pause it
before before you come what do you think
it is
a huge portion of nurses are refusing to
get the vaccine huh
no yeah um at least 153 employees by the
way
from houston methodist
wow they were fired for refusing the
vaccine one third of all nurses at the
university of cincinnati uh their
medical center said that they'd rather
quit than get the vaccine um
in new york 20 20 of hospital workers
all hospital workers not vaccinated
florida 42 percent nationally one in
four workers have not gotten vaccinated
now i know you're saying only 42 only a
third here's the thing when you've laid
off a record number of nurses because
you couldn't afford them due to putting
basically a moratorium on all treatment
that is not covered right you're
probably overextended because you built
new wings that you didn't need with
hospitals one-third that's 33 percent of
nurses refusing to be vaccinated will
absolutely have caught us catastrophic
results uh as it relates to a labor
shortage that would happen in any
industry rematch imagine 33
of people at this show gone 33 of people
on any assembly line gone
that's a huge reason yeah absolutely a
lot of these things happening at the
same time too right so this
self-inflicted wound with some spikes in
covid with the problem that people have
this massive stereo that they have to go
to the hospital uh if they have the
sniffles right so this whole like oh
delta variant surge thing and it is a
surge absolutely right but everybody is
so scared right which i don't understand
how there's a surge when seventy-five
percent of americans have received at
least we're not doctors we're not we
can't we can't talk about that don't
make an inference that's a conspiracy
theory if you go wait most people are
vaccinated but there's the same number
it's weird last year
so many people were sick who would have
ever thought go ahead i know when i'm
freaking out from being busy at a
hospital i have time to stop and talk to
the news yes
[Laughter]
so it's cheryl gerald is reading
something or our uh don jr can extend
until 10 30. oh okay wonderful um we we
got them so let's be really clear here
though because i do want to tell a story
here uh gerald and i'll tell my story
there for mug club but you can't also
argue that nurses are leaving because
let's say right now they're not being
paid fairly now as a matter of fact
hospitals want these nurses so badly
that it's you know how it's a buyer's
market it's a nurse's market right now
uh massive sign-on bonuses upwards of a
hundred dollars an hour right these are
more than some doctors make certainly
some uh like i think or other people who
are who've attended more medical school
than nursing people like some
anesthesiologists physicians assistants
miami area hospitals they're paying 80
uh 85 to 105 dollars an hour 1200 a week
in travel expenses baylor scott and
white is offering a fifteen thousand
dollar sign-on bonus why because right
now there are enough nurses they're not
just going i'm stressed they're saying
i'm i don't
i don't wanna get this vaccine whether
you think they're crazy stupid or not
because you'll say that we're not
doctors well guess what they do work in
the medical field and a significant
portion
certainly enough to disrupt the supply
chain of nurses have said they will quit
sooner than get a vaccination and gerald
your wife is a nurse and we have
permission to talk about this yeah yeah
she's a nurse and so when we talked
about what people should do with forced
vaccines which is coming up october 1st
i think is the deadline for a lot of
people in different hospital systems
country where they have to have the
vaccination or be very very very clear
about this be fired immediate there is
no grace there is nothing after that you
don't go on like some administrative
leave you don't have to work from home
you are fired you are done there are
nurses right now that are just walking
off the job like we've heard stories in
the nursing community of 20 people on
one shift saying we're just going to
leave yeah and one shift of some of the
best of the best workers that these
hospitals have leaving and going away
and so my wife mid catheter exactly like
ah you're going to have to take it out
yourself it's self-lubricating though i
saw a commercial i'll make it easier for
you hold it on the table whack it with a
hammer break it like a kitkat oh geez i
got an inch in the rest is up to you
so my wife was given the choice right
okay get the vaccine or or be fired yeah
and so at the time your pregnant wife
well so we didn't know that at the time
she's breastfeeding right now we were a
little concerned about that there are
several reasons that we're worried about
this but we're not anti-vaccines at all
my world made fun of me for saying hey
you should watch this thing about
vaccinations early on in our
relationship so it was kind of funny
we're not even close to that
then we find out my wife is pregnant
and my wife works from home 100
of the time she never even goes near the
hospital and my wife has a note from her
ob gyn who said i would not recommend
you take this and she has it from her
primary care provider unsolicited she
didn't say to give me a note she said
what do you think about this yes and
then give me a note
to that whatever you say so she's got
all of that and she's in her first
trimester do you know what they do with
first trimester pregnant women they give
you nothing they say well if you're in
the air force they give you a stretcher
you need it right yeah you start to show
them bad armor yeah so they give you
nothing they say look in the first
trimester you need to be as careful as
humanly possible and you know what
they're telling my wife right now
none of that matters yeah none of that
matters you are going to have to get the
vaccine and put your hospital or your
wife right yeah not her doctors no no no
the hospital where she works i'm not
going to i'm not going to be clear your
wife
i would assume wouldn't take ivermectin
while she's in her first trimester
either my wife won't take ibuprofen
while she while she's pregnant well well
we tell women not to eat soft cheese or
shellfish or all of these other things
and we're telling them to take a vaccine
right now that they have to mandate have
to have to have a job right and by the
way guess what happens if she gets fired
on october 1st healthcare gone now my
wife's pregnant without hellcare yeah
well also to be fair your wife though
tell people this then we're going to
bring donald trump jr on yeah she was
offered a job so just give an example
because this hospital requires
vaccinations there have been mass
walk-offs and this has been happening at
a lot of hospitals but a hospital that
does not require yeah there's sex
hospitals that don't require this one of
one of the things was that miami job was
like seven or eight grand a week no for
your wife yeah yeah so tell them i was
talking about in general your wife was
specifically offered what a signing
bonus i think it was a signing bonus of
like ten thousand dollars but it was
through those offers right so she was
she's in that group she's an icu
qualified nurse which is right top level
that you can be 10 i think it was like a
10 000 signing bonus and a huge uh
hourly rate that the bonus sorry the
overtime rate on that miami job that we
showed 225 an hour yeah 225 an hour and
36 hours is full time they wanted you to
do 48. so you can do the math you have
an amazing amount of money being offered
to people right now
because of what the hospitals are doing
to them exactly for no other reason
literally what reason can you possibly
think of for somebody who works from
home 100 of the time and you didn't give
them pregnant first try message yeah you
can give them an exception if you come
to the campus you have to have the
vaccine right what possible reason could
there be yeah and then and then they
blame you and say oh stop playing
politics with science what a second the
science says that a first trimester
pregnant woman should be taking a
vaccine with no long term stuff look
that's anything like you said when my
wife was first trimester pregnant all of
us we were
we were borderline obsessive okay it is
not unreasonable at this point it
doesn't make you anti-vaxx at all you
can say hey a 70 year old who's not
pregnant makes sense
a 32 year old who is first trimester
working from home it doesn't make sense
that is the issue that is going on right
now and they're playing politics with
science and now we are creating a labor
shortage and here's something too a lot
of people out there will offer anecdotal
evidence there can be a regional problem
in other words this kind of situation
can create a problem let's say in
houston texas where they are
overburdened absolutely and you go to a
hospital go oh it was crazy full yeah
then you go to a hospital in miami and
they say well you can go to any hospital
you want we're we're running like
clockwork right so two things can be
true you can anecdotally experience
seamless care right now or horrible care
depending how woke the hospital wants to
virtue signal if we have uh him on do we
have a stinger here coming on the show
right now of course we are thrilled uh
to have him he's always a lot of fun and
we get some good stuff is uh donald
trump jr
[Music]
all right mr trump how are you sir
i'm doing good how are you doing i i am
i'm doing better thank you for asking
you know it's a little bit tough on the
uh on the breathing front you look like
you're tan and and slim is it less
stressful being
uh you know living in florida is uh is
good compared to you know new york i can
it's just so much more active naturally
it's uh it's a little bit better i just
it's a no-brainer
um okay i have so many questions for you
first off you're commenting in the fight
with your with with your dad this
weekend evander holyfield versus the
tour belfort right
yes okay which st which roided up guy
are you are you rooting for
well listen what's sort of funny is when
i was talking to my dad about it we got
into some of this because we watched the
first one when they did uh you know the
tyson roy jones fight yeah uh we watched
it from camp david as like a family and
just had a good time and it was sort of
amazing listening to my father talk
about boxing because you see all the
things that he does but you forget that
like all those decades in atlantic city
i mean
he hosted like ufc one uh you know yeah
earlier
all of those big fights and so i'm
listening to him talk about all of these
fighters he's like you know when that
guy was fighting at 187 it was and i'm
just like oh my god like this is sort of
amazing and so his fight knowledge is
actually pretty incredible and so uh you
know i know the guys over at triller i
was going anyway i've been you know and
we're like this could be really fun and
really cool and i think it will be i
mean so it's you know saturday night uh
my father's gonna be commentating on all
of those fights and some of them are
friends tito ortiz obviously right he's
been a huge supporter politically but
he's been a friend for years i mean he
did uh you know even in his prime he was
doing you know did the apprentice and
right uh all of that stuff so you know
vitor belfort's a friend evander did a
lot with my father in all of those
fights
uh like i said the most fascinating
thing was listening to my father talk
about the history and how much recall he
had about some of the behind the scenes
stuff when those guys you know were
fighting at in atlantic city in front of
him yeah i mean he's he's been a combat
uh sport fan for a long time i'm hoping
that uh i'm hoping that you and your
your dad don't get as high as snoop dogg
and oscar de la hoya did at the last one
they were commentating i hope you do
yeah yeah listen uh yeah we're two
totalers but uh you know i imagine uh
it's still trump and trump so you know
there's probably
uh there's not a lot of filter going on
in there i mean that's right you know
tourette's you know just tourette's we
don't need to throw away tourettes of
the thumbs over there it's just gonna be
tourette yeah we don't need to throw in
the shrooms i mean oscar de la hoya
remember i was like go go little body
you're beautiful you're beautiful you're
beautiful you're beautiful he is
beautiful you are beautiful like shut
up james blunt so um
okay moving away and that is where can
people tune in really quickly because
this is something i will be watching
yeah it's pay-per-view on saturday night
uh triller's putting it on you can just
check out any of the links on my social
media it'll take you there uh but yeah
saturday night he's gonna be
commentating on all of those fights uh
down here in uh you know fort lauderdale
just gonna be a lot of fun uh good card
a lot of friends involved it's just
gonna be a good time i think uh you know
a bunch of the even current fighters and
some of the usc guys that are going to
be there because so much of that is
based in south florida yeah they're
going to come up and join us and talk i
think you know i've heard jorge mas
vidal is going to be there i heard
michael chandler's going to be there a
couple other guys so uh it should be a
lot of fun uh getting their commentary
as well and just you know watching those
guys interact with my dad and myself
yeah it uh it sounds like it's going to
be fun now i'm going to shift gears here
a little bit uh obviously with your dad
having been out of office but you guys
have been having rallies um
for me i wanted to and obviously i was
still recovering so i haven't spoken
with uh with you in a while um
what was it like or what did you think
with former vice president joe biden
attempting to blame his afghanistan
disaster
the trump administration that for me was
look let me tell you where i line up
really quickly so that that way we i i
think if someone's acts like they don't
understand the difference between
withdrawing american allies ambassadors
citizens being protected by the troops
and then taking out the troops last
while leveling all of our military bases
if they don't understand the difference
between that and withdrawing our
military protection before
our citizens i think they're being
intellectually disingenuous but
this was something the media really they
even kind of admitted biden did a bad
job but then they pivoted really quick
and said actually it's it's donald
trump's fault what was that like issues
i mean it was ridiculous i mean i mean
you can even see it like it's like oh
wow they're losing the press and they
were desperately trying but it was so
bad
even they couldn't defend it and you
know you're right there there is a
difference i i'm not going to sit here
and say oh no no we should have stayed
in afghanistan for the next two
millennia
no one thinks that uh other than maybe
the military industrial complex and some
of those dc people that are going to get
the raytheon board seat and be rich for
the rest of their lives i mean that's
their retirement john bolton is going to
be cryogenically frozen just so we can
check in in 2000 years and make sure
we're still in afghanistan but yes yeah
like you know other than those people no
one thinks we should still be at war but
you know i think joe biden and really
it's a democrat problem they're so used
to the media running cover for them
blaming anyone else
blaming everyone else uh
he didn't think that changing the plan
that my father had worked on and
negotiate would be a problem right i
mean he he delayed the entire withdrawal
till now now is the fighting season
that's what these you know animals come
out of the caves after a long winter uh
and they're bored so they're gonna go
fight and kill stuff i mean you ask any
guy that's boots on the ground and
they'll tell you this uh you know so
many of my friends that were involved
and were fighting over there they're
like i mean i can't even believe it now
our generals probably don't know that
because they've been so busy pushing
critical race theory and wanting to
learn about white rage
uh you know that they didn't think that
that would be a factor but joe biden was
so used to the press covering for him
that he was like hey man you know what
if i do this i can delay till september
11th and i can get that incredible photo
off you know like the kamala harris
photo off a thousand miles away from the
border like right as long as you're kind
of sort of traveling to the like you're
on a border it may not be the border uh
yeah it may not be you know near the
epicenter of where the problem is but we
checked that box we showed off and now
we will allow the media to do their job
as our marketing department you know so
when he was losing the media even still
was like but think about it you honestly
think
that trump would have left you know 80
billion dollars worth of equipment do
you honestly think that trump if he saw
this coming wouldn't have been droning
you know the caravans of cars coming in
to take it you know you think he would
have maybe pulled out the civilians
first i mean joe biden what he really
wanted is he wanted to make it his own
he wanted to get the credit for actually
doing this so he changed what was a
negotiated plan he eliminated all
conditions so that he could get a photo
up and take full credit for it because
they're so used to getting credit for
doing nothing uh as long as their
presence because that's what's happened
in our country in our system you know
that it's asinine i mean to think you
know that our military we have generals
that got on press conferences we
we had no way we had no way of knowing
that this could have possibly happened
i'm like i don't know i'll scroll
through instagram i'll see videos of
some of these you know afghan fighting
forces that we treat they can't do a
jumping jack you know what i'm talking
about i know exactly what you're talking
about they're on there they're on the
elliptical with a rocket launcher going
backwards yeah i was like you couldn't
see this coming like
i don't know like i could see it coming
and let's just say i know absolutely
nothing about this and i could see it
coming or blinking did you see it here
blinking quote we just played that
earlier in the show where he said uh
where uh we are concerned that they
don't have any women like who'd have
thought that that was gonna happen
i did something for you know a video for
facebook on this last night it's like
really like really like you had no idea
you're you're totally shocked that the
taliban
was not didn't turn out to be the
all-inclusive
uh and gender representing uh
administration that i mean
like
the taliban is not a mundane detail
michael south park it's like if you
animated south park and turned it into a
real life movie that is this
administration and that's what you get
when you have an administration whose
only focus
has been diversity meaning
you know it's wonderful that they have
this incredibly diverse cabinet are they
competent i don't know it doesn't seem
like that was even a criteria like
if confidence
intelligence knowledge experience is not
a criteria but like you know finding
some sort of magical unicorn that checks
off a lot of boxes you know that's what
you get and this is the result of it
yeah it's not just afghanistan you know
it's the border uh it's inflation it's
all of these things and and we're
getting to the point where even
today's insanely biased media can no
longer cover for the clown show that is
there i mean you have the secretary of
state on tv not just saying he's shocked
shocked that the taliban was not as
inclusive and diverse i mean i'm like i
don't know
again
no i think you do
it's not like they don't have 20 years
of experience realizing that the taliban
could give a [ __ ] about diversity or
inclusion you know but by the way that
will not stop
the un
from putting the taliban or their
representatives on like a human rights
council because that's the bat [ __ ]
world in which we live today stephen
yeah you know it's coming no i know it's
coming i absolutely do know that it's i
think it's 100 coming they're going to
have a seat at the table at the u.n
they'll probably even put them on some
like the council for women's rights i
mean iran i think was on there and some
of these other crazy regimes like
because we live in a clown world
and you know that's the it's like
addiction i think you know america is
going to have to hit rock bottom
for them to realize that i've said this
for months now and like every day i wake
up and be like okay like we're at rock
bottom like
man
we're not even close like two weeks ago
i thought we were at rock bottom
rock bottom then blinking's like did
someone say auger
yeah well i mean look if you're our al
imagine you're an american ally you know
who's who's making decisions you know
under the assumption the false
assumption now but what would have
historically been a good assumption that
america will be there to have your back
i mean we don't even have the backs of
our own citizens yeah we don't even have
the backs of the people who helped us
now that doesn't prevent us from
airlifting uh a hundred thousand
unvetted afghans some of whom are on
terrorist watch list of course uh some
of whom are convicted rapists we take
care of them before
we do our own citizens which is like the
most joe biden slash really democrat
party like decision ever it's like going
back to the obama biden days where it's
like you you saw him talking about it
the other day because
four of the five people that they traded
for a trader bo bergdahl
that were in guantanamo we had five
taliban terrorists in guantanamo bay
because they were bad guys we traded
those five people for a trader who
deserted americans who had americans go
out and look for him some of whom were
killed yeah we traded to get this piece
of [ __ ] back
we traded five taliban terrorists okay
and four of them are now sitting on like
the council yes and you know what by the
way let me that reminds me of fact check
myself yesterday i said three uh for
beau bergdahl it was four we forgot you
always forget that fourth
you think thirds they'll use that to
de-platform you even if you're helping
they're like it wasn't that it was only
so let's be clear that it's four
piece of [ __ ] terrorists yeah one piece
of [ __ ] traitor like that's like the
most obama biden deal ever i know and
they tried to and i i will come in here
the democrat party platform like summed
up in one sentence these clowns are now
running the taliban and we're saying you
know and over the last few weeks i'm
watching the secretary of state i'm
watching the generals well uh we we are
going to have to ask permission of the
taliban to see if maybe we can get our
citizens who we abandoned after leaving
the dogs after leaving military
equipment you know and not just military
equipment this wasn't like a couple
enforced i mean they have freaking
apaches yeah i know you know i know
they're blackhawks they're selling them
to the chinese who are reverse
engineering them and within about two
weeks they will have a helicopter that
will destroy the apache after we spend
billions in r d and years developing it
the chinese now will have that they will
reverse engineer it to create a better
piece of equipment for two cents on the
dollar after we spent trillions in
development that's how the world works
the chinese are now talking about taking
over bagram air force base that we sunk
billions in that would have been a nice
place to maybe have a presence
essentially on the border of china but
our genius military really focus on
white rage and critical race theory and
teaching us that diversity will somehow
make us a stronger fighting force no one
who actually fights understands even
remotely how that is possible but our
generals do and they have told us it uh
distinctly if you question that you will
be thrown out of the military we've seen
that yeah now if you're a you know a
lunatic uh preaching the leftist bs that
they're talking about on a daily basis
you will likely be promoted uh you know
see them you see the conservative purge
in the military i saw it i have friends
in the seal teams like literally
operators like doing they have told me
verbatim
they spend more time in diversity
training than they do shooting
yeah seal teams okay so imagine what
they're doing with like you know less
elite
you know forms imagine who's taking this
over when the military is paying for
your transgender surgery and
highlighting it right you've seen the
highlight reels like menstruating
people's videos
i am i am
i have incredible anxiety i can barely
function in the real world i have no
idea what's going on around me but the
cia was incredibly welcoming and i am
your first line of defense i'm saying
holy [ __ ]
i mean remember this you know what i'm
talking about right i know exactly what
you're talking about yes this guy he's a
wonderful person i'm sure he is probably
not capable of going to the supermarket
without being in fear he is leading
like our our charges in the intelligence
community against like china and russia
you think like they're looking at that
and being like oh wow we got a problem
here you think sweet like if you're
china
your plans which were inevitable
probably but your plan to take over
taiwan
just accelerated whatever it used to be
it's like
one percent of that yeah within weeks
probably because they know america's got
no balls well hold on a second i want to
i want to continue that we're going to
go here to mud club where you can you
know really let it rip i guess but no i
agree with you i think they want the
military holding back stephen no no no
it's perfect but i don't want to be
accused of being low energy yeah no it's
just with if we talk about covet at all
i guarantee you will be removed so i
want to avoid that one that's just
that's no longer a mine field it's one
big mine with no more fuel left uh i
will say this yeah they they want us to
turn the military into we have great
members in the military like you've
talked about there's different people on
the ground and people at desk they want
to turn them from uh uh was it missing
an action two to that shitty little
planeteer with the power of hearts and
that's not how it works in the real
world we're gonna continue with donald
trump jr uh at mug club people join up
crowder come back you get twenty dollars
off youtube it's time for youtube
piss off lou
[Music]
bye